jimmy bon on a des raisons de
s'inquiéter ou pas on a des pistes
d'espoir le vaccin c'est l'espoir ça à
venir à bout du tunnel
il faut dire que on a enfin la clé du
problème la seule question c'est quand
est ce qu'on va enfin trouver ses clés
quand est ce qu'on va nous les données
pour puisse sortir de l'impression qu'il
est un gigantesque incendie en france et
que au lieu d'appeler les pompiers on
prendra cet extincteur et on y va à jour
après jour mais on espère que d'ici
quelques mois on sera enfin sorti de
l'auberge bernard nombreux sont ceux qui
se demandent ce que s'ils ont déjà eu la
combine 19 et doivent se faire vacciner
ouais alors c'est ça l'histoire ouais
c'est une vraie question leur a pu aussi
se poser se dire les personnes qui
auraient été immunisés qui ont eu une
sérologie positive suite à une infection
peut-être qu'on pourrait retarder un
petit peu leur vaccination la seule
question c'est qu'on ne sait pas combien
de temps ces gens sont protégés donc
faire une sérologie tous les deux trois
mois six mois
mais oui c'est nous la question peut
peut-être décalé et mettre le paquet sur
les personnes qui n'ont jamais été
malades et protéger les plus fragiles
là on vaccine les ehpad les personnes
qui sont donc les plus fragiles c'est un
tiers des morts lors de l'épidémie
alors que c'est un pour cent de la
population donc il faut les protéger
mais ça veut dire que deux tiers des
décès ont lieu ailleurs que dans les
ehpad et donc il faut aller les protégés
et faut protéger les français qui sont
chez eux à domicile qui attendent que ça
ya une question est ce qu'on peut
attraper la co vide quand on est
vaccinés dans c'est fini alors le vaccin
du roman gaiser 95 % d'efficacité
maintenant on veut dire que vous me
vacciner dix personnes neuf neuf et demi
qui sera protégé sais pas combien de
temps ça va durer la question c'est
est-ce que l'année prochaine il faudra
se re faire vacciner par comme la brique
la grippe si le vaccin mute comme en
angleterre est ce que ça va marcher
ce qui est rassurant c'est que les
laboratoires ont dit en cas de mutation
du virus
nous sommes capables de produire un
nouveau vaccin dans les six semaines
c'est une révolution
vas-y reculé on pourra peut-être
retrouver une vie normale sous
vaccination on le fait pour la grippe
peut-être qu'on le fera pour le court
navires us et en corée mais oui arrive
en question un peu m ça peut ça peut
muter combien de fois un virus comme ça
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
cours navires us à un virus à arn qui
fait beaucoup de copies en raison des
copies commet des erreurs et abouti
cette relaxe
un peu abouti à un changement de
fonction du virus soit beaucoup plus
fort soit beaucoup moins forces à celles
à l'aller a en revanche si on fait un
peu comme les anglais ou les américains
c'est à dire qu'ils ont dit peut-être
qu'on va vacciner avec une seule dose au
lieu des deux doses que ça nous on fait
les doses nous on devra faire les deux
espèces qui recommande et l'association
d'urgence mais avec une dose il est
possible que s'entraînent une
question de sélection sur le virus et
qu'il mute pour essayer d'échapper à la
vaccination et multi une nouvelle fois
et devenir encore plus fort ou au
contraire s'éteindre est ce que quand on
est vaccinés on peut donner le transport
c'est la question à l'histoire on se
posait la question les applications ya
un risque de transmission pas bien une
étude qui vient de paraître dans un
grand journal s'appelle new england qui
montre que la vaccination empêche la
maladie donc c'est une très bonne chose
ou une direction animation vous ne
déciderait pas mais en plus empêche la
transmission ca confirmés par d'autres
études c'est extraordinaire ça veut dire
que d'ici quelques temps on pourra
espérer si on est tous vaccinés
retrouver une vie normale
enlever ces masques et puis aurore
revivra comment ces actifs
c'est légal
oui il a fait sans escale aux étoffes de
vous appeler tiffany non non passeport
est ce qu'on peut avoir le 25 entre les
deux injections
le quoi non le virus mardon est-ce qu'on
va avoir des injections alors c'est vrai
qu on a l'impression que tu vois que les
vaccinés on est tranquille il faut deux
injections avec trois semaines
d'intervalle c'est ça une immunité mon
progressivement il faut un mois avant
d'être protégé ça veut dire que si vous
rencontrez de coronavirus une semaine
après la vaccination rencontrés y sommes
c'est nous qui faisons circuler sur ses
actes le virus circule mais c'est nous
qui lui valurent escaliers j'adore quand
il si vous rencontrez le courant d'un
virus tel que j'ai pas envie de te
comptage fait une mise au po la renommée
est ce qu'on a le stock de vaccins ce
que les questions d'accès et c'est vrai
que il annonce 15 millions de box inc du
6 juin et si on n'a pas les vaccins pour
ballet vacciner 500000 vaccins par
semaine on voit pas aller très loin
dépassé d'union européenne et on aurait
pu essayer de sortir des sentiers battus
à mort israël c'est à dire on va aller
négocier dans l'urgence
honnêtement c'est la catastrophe mais
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent alors pas je
sais pas c'est une vraie question qu'est
ce qu'ils attendent et on pourra aussi
faire autre chose ça a été proposé de
donner des licences à des industriels
pharmaceutiques français et européen la
licence files heures pendant
l'autorisation d'euros produire le
vaccin voyant des commissions à mais
nous aidons à voler massivement nous on
a voulu vacciner bernard montiel et
isabelle moign mais c'est un bordel
comment on fait pour se faire vacciner
ils nous ont dit ouais on n'a jamais eu
le bac 5 a montré pour la france
besoin est en première ligne non mais
c'est vrai il faut attendre pour
l'instant ça va être les personnes dans
les ehpad les personnels soignants ne
faut pas aller dans un ehpad
mais on n'a pas le droit de les vacciner
non mais en attendant il va falloir
attendre et à la fin du mois ce sera les
personnes de plus de 75 ans on diminuera
petit à petit donc la vaccination global
on a par contre les gros chêne